2007 like that's a long time ago when we
were you know just boys
greetings Upper East Siders lonely boy
and n were just spotted reminiscing
about the good old days it was like
college for us you know we kind of grew
up together so that was a very good
experience yeah okay but really Penn
Badgley and chase Crawford caught up
over video chat four varieties actors on
actor series and took a stroll down
memory lane recalling their time on
Gossip Girl some of the most fun moments
are like you know that the Dayton and
the naiton dancing Penn played Dan
Humphrey and chase played Nate Archibald
on the hit show about high school
students at an exclusive prep school on
Manhattan's Upper East Side those are
good days though man I don't even
remember what our like first moment was
on set I mean I remember the palace the
palace hotel but and that was our
Tiller's town new york really - oh it
was mine it was definitely my first time
like experiencing New York and yeah yeah
I mean we really got the you got you got
they got the red carpet right away who
could forget the Palace Hotel how do you
know it was miss van der Woodsen's if
you didn't read it and if you're not a
guest at the hotel what were you doing
here
but for Penn the Gossip Girl days feel
like a distant memory it feels like
another lifetime to me like I did when I
think that being at the Palace of the
Palace Hotel that just feels like I feel
like a different person it feels like
another world another life it's pretty
wild Jay said that the cast was treated
like royalty right from the jump I'm
sure I remember the name of the because
it was Pete like the manager there yes
dude yeah Jarrett was a pea I wish I
knew he was the best but he'd always
like we're sitting there you know in the
courtyard in between tanks he's just
gonna be like Tamra loves you and just
like walk away yeah and Penn who dated
their co-star Blake Lively during
filming had his own memory of the palace
hotels manager when Blake and I went
there to eat got like a grilled cheese
sandwich and suggested I was just like I
was they had a grilled cheese sandwich
there called the gossip girl grilled
cheese sandwich
and I was helping and and I was
delighted you should have called the
gossip grill and then he was like took
the menu from me went back printed it
change the name right there printed a
different menu and handed me a new menu
with my suggestion and I was like okay
this is a this is a way to live the show
aired from 2007 to 2012 and chase
admitted he hadn't watched the show
since it wrapped have you seen it
recently buddy I mean that was on the
question list I was going to ask so
that's a hard pass for Chase
but pen said when he first started
dating his now-wife Domino they watched
a few episodes together it's like man I
can see how self-conscious I was I can
see I can see so you have exactly I
don't like really watching myself that
much in general so to go back and open
that time capsule I mean we lived it you
know I think I think there won't be some
nostalgic you know value possibly to so
we're doing that when you come to LA
we'll have a drink uh
can we come until then this mini Gossip
Girl reunion will just have to do
affiliation when et caught up with Penn
in 2018 he said fans shouldn't hold
their breaths for a full blown cast
reunion I can't see how it would happen
just for so many reasons and they don't
even have to do anything to do with me I
just don't like it's gonna happen and
then if I was asked I would say we'd
have to depend on things that can't be
known until that day and Chase is pretty
much on the same page as Penn it's the
age of reboots two people asked about
all the time gonna come back I've heard
that a few times yeah you know
we're getting a little too old to be
Devi in college and to be and heads of
the newspaper well a year later HBO max
announced a Gossip Girl reboot is in the
works and will premiere in 2021
I'm not come back is a father and Penn
told et we shouldn't expect to see Dan
Humphrey again anytime soon either
could Dan Humphrey I don't you know
that's again these things are I that's a
that's a that's a message I got to put
at the top of my inbox you know the
context it to think about um I've not
had conversations as any the creators
yet but Penn did tell chase the whole
thing has him intrigued I'm so much is
it to see what it's like I'm so
interested I wish him well I I really am
also interested to see how people react
to it
[Music]